>> Laura: HOW TO DO BE THE
SWAMP'S EFFORTS TO TAKE DOWN
FROM HIS NOMINEES.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE" ."
IT HAS BEEN 15 MONTHS SINCE THE
TRUMP INAUGURATION AND YET THERE
ARE STILL MORE THAN 500
POSITIONS ACROSS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT HAVE YET TO BE
FILLED BY TRUMP APPOINTEES.
THESE RANGE FROM ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OF STATE TO POLITICAL
MILITARY AFFAIRS TO ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
FOR POLICY.
NOW FOR MY OWN EXPERIENCE IN
BOTH THE EDUCATION DEPARTMENT,
THE TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT,
AND ALSO AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
IT IS NOT THE ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OR A ASSOCIATE DEPUTY
LEVEL, THAT IS WHERE ALL THE
WORK GETS DONE.
THE FAULT LIES PARTLY IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ITSELF.
THINK ABOUT THIS, THE OFFICE OF
PRESIDENTIAL PERSONNEL, REALLY
IMPORTANT, IT RUNS THE
PRESIDENT'S STAFFING, IT IS NOW
OVERBURDENED AND UNDERSTAFFED.
OBAMA'S OFFICE OF PRESIDENTIAL
PERSONNEL HAD THREE TIMES THE
STAFF OF WHAT TRUMP HAS.
IT TAKES PEOPLE, ACTUAL
EMPLOYEES IN THAT OFFICE TO
PROCESS NAMES, SHEPHERD THE
VETTING PROCESS, AND DO REAL
FOLLOW-THROUGH ON PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUGGESTED TO VARIOUS POSITIONS.
I REALIZE THAT TRUMP WANTS TO
CUT THE SIZE OF GOVERNMENT BUT
THERE ARE BETTER PLACES TO CUT
THEN OPP.
MOST RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
TRAVESTY, THOUGH, OF ALL THESE
DELAYS AND ALL THE FOOT
DRAGGING, ARE THE DEMOCRATS.
STOPPING TRUMP FROM PUTTING HIS
OWN PEOPLE IN KEY POSITIONS,
WHAT DOES IT DO?
IT SLOWS DOWN TRUMP'S PROGRESS.
431 OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
NOMINEES HAVE RECEIVED SENATE
CONFIRMATION.
THAT'S A FAR LOWER NUMBER THAN
ANY OTHER PRESIDENT AT THIS
POINT IN THEIR TERM.
NOW DEMOCRATS HAVE CONTINUOUSLY
INVOKED A RULE THAT REQUIRES 30
HOURS OF DEBATE ON MANY OF
TRUMP'S APPOINTEES.
SO THAT MEANS THAT NOMINEES WAY
TO AN AVERAGE OF 84 DAYS FOR
CONFIRMATION, THAT'S A LOT
LONGER ALSO THAN PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS.
MORE THAN 50% OF TRUMP'S
NOMINEES FOR FEDERAL JUDGESHIPS
ARE STILL AWAITING CONFIRMATION.
DEMOCRATS OBSTRUCTION EFFORTS
ARE HAVING A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
THE BASIC FUNCTIONS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.
IT CAUSES INEFFICIENCIES, AND IT
EVEN CAN PUT OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY AT RISK.
THE SENATE HAS YET TO ACT ON THE
DIPLOMATIC POSTS, MOST NOTABLY,
WITH RICHARD GRENELL, THE
HARVARD EDUCATED DIPLOMAT IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NOMINEE TO BE
AMBASSADOR FOR GERMANY.
HE IS BEING HELD UP BY ONE
DEMOCRAT SENATOR.
JEFF MURPHY OF OREGON.
WHAT COULD MITCH McCONNELL DO
TO MOVE THINGS ALONG AS A SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER?
HE COULD TELL CHUCK SCHUMER THE
FOLLOWING.
HEY, CHUCK, THE SENATE IS NOT
GOING TO RECESS UNTIL YOU ALL
START DISPENSING WITH THIS 30
HOUR RULE AND START ALLOWING
VOTES ON HUMAN NOMINEES.
THESE GUYS WANT TO GET HOME ON
THE WEEKENDS.
IF HE NEEDS TO CHANGE OR
DISPENSE WITH THE FILIBUSTER
RULE, HE MAY NEED TO DO THAT,
TOO.
YOU CAN'T LET THIS CONTINUE.
TO REMEMBER IN 2013, THEN SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER HARRY REID BLEW
UP THE FILIBUSTER RULE FOR FEDER
UP THE FILIBUSTER RULE FOR FEDEL
APPOINTEES IN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH LIKE CABINET OFFICIALS
AND THE JUDICIAL BRANCH.
THIS IS HOW OBAMA WAS ABLE TO
PACK THE LOWER COURTS AS HE DID.
TRUMP COULD DO THE SAME HERE.
DONALD TRUMP HAS FRANKLY BEEN
ASKING FOR THAT.
BUT NOW SOME ARE LOOKING TO PUT
ANOTHER SCALP ON THE WALL, I'M
TALKING THE DEMOCRATS, WHO DO
THEY WANT?
MIKE POMPEO'S SCALP.
TRUMP'S CIA DIRECTOR, WHO HAS
BEEN NOMINATED FOR SECRETARY OF
STATE.
NOW DURING HIS CONFIRMATION
HEARING, AMERICA SAW THE
DEMOCRATS'S DEMONIZATION GAME ON
FULL DISPLAY.
AUDITIONING FOR 2020 WAS NEW
JERSEY'S CORY BOOKER.
>> IS BEING GAY A PERVERSION?
>> WHEN I WAS A SENATOR GRAHAM I
HAD A VERY CLEAR VIEW OVER
WHETHER IT WAS APPROPRIATE FOR
TWO SAME-SEX PEOPLE TO GET
MARRIED.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT ({GAYS
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT ({GAYX
IS A PERVERSION?
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS CLAIM TO
BE AGAINST DISCRIMINATION EXCEPT
WHEN THEY ARE DISCRIMINATING.
IF YOU ARE SOMEONE WHO HOLDS A
TRADITIONAL OUTLOOK, LIKE ANY
FAITHFUL CATHOLIC FOR INSTANCE,
OTHER CHRISTIANS, SHOULD WE NOW
ASSUME THAT YOU NEED NOT APPLY
TO ANY OF THESE POSITIONS?
THEN THERE WERE SWINGS AND
MESSES, LIKE THIS ONE FROM
SENATOR JEANNE SHAHEEN.
>> YOU WERE CRITICIZED AT THE
CIA FOR UNDERMINING POLICIES OF
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION TO
IMPROVE DIVERSITY AT THE CIA.
>> I DON'T KNOW THE CRITICISM
THAT YOU REFERRING TO.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I DIDN'T
UNDERMINE A SINGLE POLICY.
>> I WOULD JUST SAY COME ON
MICHAEL WEINSTEIN, FORMER
AIR FORCE OFFICER WHO FOUNDED
THE MILITARY RELIGIOUS FREEDOM